now we're in war and we're drivers and
we shouldn't be plus drivers across the
Las Vegas Valley say they're soldiers in
a battle they didn't sign up for the 8
news now investigation continuing right
now with the incidents those three bus
drivers you just met have seen with
their own eyes including the stabbing on
bus 115 and one operator fighting to
breathe
do not make any moves towards your
waistband this Las Vegas Metro Police
body cam video records moments after
this man Randy black gets off to Misha
Davis's bus I'll look in my rear view
mirror I see him running up to this man
stabbing him I'll pull my bus over I
push the panic button
no answer it's 2021 Davis is driving her
room the 115. when police say black
stabbed another passenger video the 8
news now investigators obtained shows
that bus pulled over police surrounding
it documents revealing the passenger
quote unprovoked stood up and began to
stab the victim numerous times before
running off so John 1 I have the knife
that's on his right hip it's a uh a
silver kitchen knife police arresting
black minutes later the knife covered in
blood they ended up catching him
said that he had his life shoved up in
his pants was a butcher knife Tamisha
Sandra Adams and Stephanie Davis are all
coach operators we're in war
and we're drivers and we shouldn't be
every day they say is like combat not
only that you gotta watch good traffic
too Stephanie's worst day on the job she
had to get me off the bus and help me to
get some oxygen was when a passenger
blue suspected methamphetamine residue
in her face I'm thinking he thinks this
pipe thing is his bus pass well no he
pulls it out under the window that they
talk about it still has space
he blows something out of the pipe the
report the 8 news now investigators
obtained for that incident says she
pulled the bus over and called for help
but ultimately police were unable to
locate that passenger Metro Police say
RTC never provided them any surveillance
video no security was ever provided but
three weeks straight I went without
security then I kept refusing to drive
from violent assaults us women get
trashed when I say belligerent
belligerent to verbal attacks a couple
of weeks ago was a guy on my bus he
wanted my number I said I'm married
sweetie he said I don't care I'll kill
you and your husband these drivers say
each day in that war on their buses are
battles they're not winning I go to work
with my mindset that I'm not getting any
altercations with anybody
I'm just going to drive if they don't
pay they don't pay
I'm not dealing with that my life is
worth more than two dollars why continue
to do the job I love meeting the people
should RTC and the bus companies be
liable if something happens
yes
much more than just violence on the bus
RTC says dispatchers and police are now
able to see inside the buses in real
time with some new cameras and they do
say that they've added some new security
guards it appears that they believe
that's sufficient and the drivers though
of course they disagree with that they
want a Transit Police Department and
they say they could walk off the job at
this point if nothing happens I mean
hearing from those drivers is startling
I mean I wonder why this hasn't happened
because we see that in other major
cities David right of course a city like
New York City has a Transit Police
Department Boston has a Transit Police
Department police department well the
board that's overseeing ROTC says that
state law actually prevents them from
having a Transit Police Department they
can only employ police so this would
have to all the way go back up to Carson
City they're dealing with a lot of stuff
right now we know that so this is going
to take a long time and it's really up
to the lawmakers there
all right David very interesting report
you can watch David's reporting into
safety on our buses in town including
how it took four minutes for a bus to
pull over while a man was being murdered
right now at our website and inside our
8 News Now app